so going back to frank amadeo how close
are you to being done with this book
i'm probably a week away from being done
a week away yeah from being that then i
have to send it have a bunch of people
read it
okay you know okay i mean i i got i've
got just friends like my friend stacy
will read it
oh you mean read the audio version or
just like read it to catch misspellings
or like no just read it to catch
misspellings typos you know what if who
knows what
who knows what i did i actually have a
bunch of guys that have contacted me
i had this chick that read one of my
books and called a bunch of
she had bought it read it contacted me
and said look you know you got a few
typos and i was like really
she goes yeah she goes do you want me to
read it and catch the typos i was like
sure
she did a great job wow
that's amazing so you know people have
to read the book
somebody might i really want frank to
come on this podcast but i don't think
he's going to do it
i don't know mr amadeo i don't know
i don't know what happened with that
does he know that you're selling shirts
with his face on it
i'm actually not actually
not you're trying
no i'm not if you look there's none on
the that's smart
i sent it to you just like hey look at
this oh i was like
a dry run yeah i didn't okay you're not
on the store
yeah his his stories on like i have a
shirt with his story on it
okay it's insanity that's got a little
picture of him but
it was a tiny picture like a whole
nother like the one you saw yeah yeah
yeah so that's great
is anybody watching this thing no
nobody's watching yeah
200 people in the chat right now you pay
attention to anything going on
in the world like of real estate or in
the world of finance
i watched graham steffen sometimes
graham stefan yeah i watch him sometimes
really
yeah why do you watch him stefan we had
him on the podcast yeah
he's great i mean it's unrealistic
some of the stuff like that the houses
that he talks about and stuff is
it doesn't really relate to florida you
know what i'm saying like you're buying
a two million dollar house or a million
dollar house or okay well
people getting into real estate you know
aren't typically buying those types of
properties but
overall the base basically everything
he's saying is is accurate
i watched one the other day you talked
about credit yeah he has he
actually has a lot of really solid
information yeah he's got about credit
and how to like
build your credit up it's like really
cool stuff yeah he's a smart kid yeah
yeah he's great but you know the only
problem is when he starts talking about
like you know
as soon as he starts a million two
million or you're like gee are you
serious
i mean as soon as i hear those numbers
i'm like and then you know but it's
california
you can buy a ranch in california for
two and a half million dollars
the same one you'd buy here for a
hundred and fifty or two hundred dollars
it is outrageous i was just looking in
texas
the price to buy a house like you would
look at a house on the beach here
that would go for like five million
bucks right you can buy a house
identical to that in texas for like
three four hundred grand is it on the
beach yes
on the like same i'm talking about like
the same like the same exact house same
water but it's it's like three times
the price here at least in florida
on the north coast it's insane i look at
houses in eboard city where i was buying
them for 40 and 50 60 000
houses are selling for 200 000 250 and
it's like
that's 250 that would imagine if you
still owned a couple of those
well that's uh that that boat sale
do you think do you think graham steffen
is all the numbers that he talks about
and all the big money he talks about do
you think it's
i i mean i think it's yeah i think he's
legit i think it's because he makes most
of his money off youtube
he does he doesn't make like his ratio
from income like from his real estate
versus
youtube right is i would say probably 90
youtube right 10 real estate
it's like for sure but that's what i
guess
that's what is i guess that's his niche
right so it's like these guys that
that do the seminars where they teach
you how to flip houses
and you're you know it's like okay well
why are you
teaching you know if you're so amazing
at flipping houses you can make so much
money why aren't you flipping houses
right and of course what why because 90
[ __ ] 80 90
of my income is derived from these from
teaching these courses
selling the course selling the courses i
make way more and it's way easier
yeah to do that course than it is to
actually go out and yeah and flip the
houses
there's not as much risk and yeah it's a
problem because
that's what happens with a lot of people
especially in real estate or other
online courses they they build up like
this huge audience where people like
them they have this big fan base
like [ __ ] now let me figure out
something to sell so i can make more
money
right so you think oh this guy's a
really good at this one thing he's like
a guru
at finance or real estate or whatever
the [ __ ] it might be
selling cotton candy and they just sell
that thing
because it's just an additional revenue
to their
income from youtube or their media a lot
of times it eventually becomes their
entire revenue
right what i'm saying like you're not
you're like you're a stock broker giving
stock advice and before you know it
you're not
you're not really buying you're not even
a stock broker anymore yeah you're
making more money doing that
yeah so uh so i'm sure that's what's
happened with
with uh yeah there's a lot of guys like
that yeah i'm sure that's what happened
with graham stephanie probably started
the channel off just to do it have
something to do do it on the side
maybe i can build it up it'll be a
little bit extra extra money and the
next thing you know you know he's did it
for a year or so and next thing you know
it probably started ballooning up and he
started realizing
hey if i really focus on this it makes
him more money to focus on writing the
content than it does to actually
do the stuff he's talking about right
and it's probably
more fun and less work for his
personality mm-hmm
you know so yeah he's gonna introduce
his personality does he want to drive
around
all day drive people around show them
houses look
you know spend days with people and then
they end up ah we decided not to do it
or we're going oh guess what last minute
oh we found another house my my wife's
cousin's a realtor i didn't know it and
he's got a house we found that one we're
going to go with him
yeah i spent a week driving around
that's got to be such a pain in the ass
to be a real estate agent
or a real estate broker what an awful
job
it it really is it it's it's a horrible
job rehabbing's a horrible job being a
mortgage broker is a horrible job
you get these people that come in lousy
they come in they they waste your time
they
they you tell them to get all these
documents they lie to you
i love it when people would come and
just blatantly lie to me and then you
say okay
i need this and this and this and
they're like oh i don't have that
really so you make 200 000 a year
working for this
law firm but you can't provide a w-2
or your taxes yeah stop it what are you
doing you pull their credit it's crap
you're like what are you doing don't lie
to me bro i'm trying to help you here
tell me what the deal is i'll figure it
out
but you know they it's just they they
they just suck
people suck that's why i started getting
rid of all the people they were too hard
to deal with
so i just started fabricating all the
all the documents and
and making fake people like this is too
much work it's too much problems easier
to create fake people
they quit their jobs like three days
before i had a guy i was getting like
getting like sixty thousand dollars out
of his house
so we're go your closings on like
tuesday
you know and then like on monday he knew
the closing was the next day like he
walks in and quits his job
and they call the mortgage company like
calls like the day
before and says hey is you know does mr
johnson
you know work there and they go uh well
actually he did but he just quit he just
he's leaving with his boxes right now
and you're like
what the [ __ ] they would actually call
the day before closing yeah i've had
them you know what's so funny
usually they close a few call a few days
or a week before
i've had them close call after the
closing which always killed me and you
don't i only know this because
i'm the borrower so i make a fake person
and then
they never called to verify which is not
uncommon
and then it was like hey they never did
call and i thought that's weird and then
like a week later
they call hi just checking to make sure
that uh um you know gary sullivan you
know
uh you know works there and it's like
i got checks in the bank i'm already
removing the cash what if he didn't work
there
you know of course i always said he
still works here
but numb nuts i mean and it's not once
we're talking about multiple times
that's happened yeah they're just
they're overwhelmed or something i don't
know
what if you're self-employed then what
how do you how do you provide
two years you know 1040s you have to
provide your your taxes two years of
1040s
right but then who are you going to call
to verify it well you don't you can if
it's in the middle of the year if it's
like in the second quarter then they'll
typically ask for like a um
a profit or loss or um or sometimes a
certified profit loss like they want an
actual
cpa or like an accountant to actually
certify this is what he's made to date
or they'll ask for a copy of your bank
statements or something just to kind of
prove
hey he's you know he's he is making
money he is still making money
yeah um and then you know well they had
the
the whole uh light doc programs where
they would ask for like
12 months worth of your bank statements
i know they have to figure out they have
to figure i remember i remember this
specif
specifically is that your your debt to
income
yeah including your including your
mortgage your dti has to be
your debt has to be less than i think 40
of your total income uh is that what it
was well i mean if it's
if it depends if it's like fha it's like
under like 41
if it was subprime it was typically
under like 45
it's like where the banks are just
making their own rules okay if it's
connected so the banks can
make those rules for themselves it's not
like a standard there's no like
like federal guidelines no that's if
it's if it's standard like a
conventional loan
which is like set by fannie mae or
freddie mac then
those are considered you know
conventional loans those are the ones
with the really good interest rates
because you're borrowing from the fed
well those uh your dti would have to be
like below 36 percent
or 38 depends on the program but yeah
below 36 so it's
your new mortgage payment all the bills
showing all the monthly bills showing up
on your
actual um bank statement credit report
credit report so if your
payment well your car payment your
credit minimum credit card balance your
minimum credit card payments
plus your new mortgage all of that
together
you're reoccurring debt monthly debt all
that together divided by whatever you
make in a month but wait they don't go
through your bank statements and look at
how much you're spending on gas how much
you're spending on groceries how much
[ __ ] you're buying how how much now they
could go
so so say for example you make 50 grand
a month right
and you only have one car payment and a
mortgage right now and that that may
only add up to
10 grand a month right and you're w-2
are you are you an employee or are you
self-employed self-employed well then
they would
ask for your your 1040s like hey he made
he made if you made if you made 600 000
last year and let's say 590 000 or 550
000 a year before
you know which is basically 50 000 a
year and you said hey it's
it's now july and i've been making 60
000. they already have something to base
that off on we got two years taxes that
show he makes about fifty thousand
so now they're going to look at your
bank statements and say he's still
he's making a hundred thousand he's
spending this much every month
going out to pay employees and whatever
he still has about a hundred thousand
about fifty thousand
left plus he's got then they might
that's assuming you don't if they don't
request a
um a cpa to do a uh to do a certified
right i guess to simplify my question is
dti they don't look at money in
money out of your bank account they only
look at what's on your the
debt on your credit report to yes
figure out what you're doing pretty much
pretty much the simplest version of that
the simple answer is yes
they typically don't ask for your bank
statements unless they're just looking
for where your down payment's coming
[Laughter]
from